and as a way to get more people
vaccinated some states have turned to
lotteries and
companies have offered up some freebies
nevada is preparing its own program
as it lags behind other states in the
rollout sasha loftis spoke with a local
expert about the efforts to reach
herd immunity sasha
denise the governor is expected to
announce a vaccine incentive program
here locally tomorrow
nevada is still lagging far behind other
states though when it comes to
vaccination
rates so i spoke to a local expert
tonight about what that means
as our nation's covet 19 vaccine rollout
continues
many still have mixed feelings if you
think it's risky to take the vaccine i
think it's also a risk to not take the
vaccine
not to say that i would never get
vaccinated but as of today i i just kind
of want to sit back and observe
but a number of nevadans on the fence
has led to low vaccination numbers
on wednesday our state health department
reported 42 percent of those 12 and
older as fully vaccinated
that's far below places like new york
and vermont
which are touting rates of 70 to 80
percent
even if you have a lot of the population
vaccine you can still have clusters
of people that come together who are
unvaccinated and that's where disease
spreads
infectious disease epidemiologist brian
labis says
while herd immunity won't completely
stop the disease
it will curb community-wide outbreaks we
can still see people get sick and die
from this even with those low
transmission rates
labis calls vaccines everyone's best bet
for protection
and a lot of southern nevadans are all
for it i would wonder why they're
hesitant
but others say no matter the decision
each person's choice
is up to them i think you have to look
at the whole situation because
everyone's situation is so different
brian labis did say the casinos in the
resort corridor are reporting
90 percent vaccination rates among
employees he says this is a really
important step to protect
locals from any tourist transmission of
covet 19.
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now